DO YOU HAVE YOU HAVE MEETINGS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW TO CALL ON
OKAY.
OKAY WITHIN THE GOOD.
HOW DO YOU FIX THAT?
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN.
AND WELCOME THE SENATE.
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
MEETING AND I AM SO HAPPY THAT
YOU'RE ALL HERE. TO HONOR AND
HAVE REPRESENT TENDED KNOWLEDGE
OF MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM.
AND THOSE WHO ARE SERVING
DILIGENT THREE THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD AND I THANK YOU.
SO THE VETERANS IN THE HOUSE I'D
LIKE YOU TO PLEASE STAND TO BE
RECOGNIZED.
VETERANS IN THE HOUSE PLEASE
STAND TO BE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND AS THEY
TEACH AS THE CHAIR I WILL DO
THIS EVERY MEDIUM AND AND
SENATORS PLEASE REMIND ME IF I
FORGET TO ACKNOWLEDGE OUR MEN
AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM.
AND WE'LL WE'LL BEGIN WITH THIS.
CHAU WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM AT
THIS TIME.
SO WE'RE STILL MISSING ONE BUT
IF WE WHEN WILL WE WILL START AS
YEAH.
SO WE HAVE SO WE WILL WE WILL
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE SO.
MADAM CHAIR WOULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL YES SIR [inaudible]
ARTS LETTERS [inaudible]
YOUR GROWTH [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WILK.
SO WE DO HAVE A WE HAVE A FORM
HAVE A POINT THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH.
THAT'S RIGHT COME MYSELF SO WE
HAVE A QUORUM.
IN THE LADIES AND JUMP JUST FOR
YOUR INFORMATION WILL WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE CONTINUE WITH OUR
VOTING.
IF WE DON'T WE GOING TO
SUBCOMMITTEE AND IT TAKES JUST
UNTIL WE BRING THE QUORUM BACK
IN AND WE RE VOTE.
SO WE WILL CONTINUE ONCE.
SO THIS IS OUR FIRST.
BILL HEARING FOR THE YEAR.
AND WE ASK -- ALL OF YOU IF
YOU'RE ASKED TO SPEAK IN YOUR
GROUP COME UP SPEAK STATE YOUR
NAME CLEARLY.
AND YOUR UNIT ORGANIZATION
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE SO WE CAN
ALL HEAR YOU -- CHAU LET'S BEGIN
BY THIS BEING OUR FIRST HEARING
AND WE I'LL ASK COMMITTEE. FOR
THE ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE
RULES [inaudible]
MOTION [inaudible]
PLEASE READ [inaudible]
ROLL.
YES SIR -- ARCHULETA.
YES I BROUGH [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
BROUGHT [inaudible]
I AMBER [inaudible]
WILK.
IN THE THE THE THE COMMITTEE
RULES OF PASSED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
EXCEPT NOW LEGEND JOHN WE HAVE
OF FOR BILLS ON OUR CALENDAR
TODAY.
AND WE HAVE NO BILLS ON CONSENT
SO WE WILL ADDRESS EACH AND
EVERY BILL.
SO OUR FIRST BILL IS US SENATE
BILL TWO FORTY FIVE AND THEN
LINK CHIANG -- YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT YOUR BILL.
AND ALONG WITH ANY OTHER
WITNESSES YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
TODAY I AM HERE TO PRESENT SB
TWO FOUR FIVE OR WHAT I LIKE TO
REFER TO AS PETS FOR VETS ACT.
THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE
LIMITED THIS BILL TO DOGS AND
CATS ONLY AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ME STAFF FOR THEIR INPUT
ON THESE CHANGES.
THIS BILL WOULD WAIVE ADOPTION
FEES AT LOCAL PUBLIC ANIMAL
SHELTERS FOR MILITARY VETERANS.
MANY OF WHOM SEEK EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT ANIMAL COMPANIONS THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO NEARLY TWO
MILLION VETERANS.
SOME OF WHOM ARE COPING WITH
PTSD OR OTHER SERVICE RELATED
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL VETERANS IN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY.
BUT THOSE WHO TURN TO ANIMAL
COMPANIONS BUT WITH YES IN OTHER
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS.
ANIMAL COMPANIONS HAVE SHOWN
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO LOWER
DEPRESSION.
LOWER LEVELS OF THE SOCIAL
ISOLATION AND PROVIDE AN OVERALL
GREATER SATISFACTION WITH LIFE.
AS A LONGTIME DOG OWNER I CAN
ATTEST TO THE JOY OF A PET RINGS
ONE'S LIFE.
IS LEGISLATION WAS MADE FOR
PEOPLE LIKE LORRAINE.
CNN WHO I RECENTLY MET WITH IN
MY DISTRICT OFFICE SHE AS A US
ARMY ARMY VETERAN WHO SERVED SIX
YEARS IN IRAQ.
AFTER RETURNING HOME LORRAINE
SOUGHT.
THE COMFORT AND COMPANIONSHIP.
OF AN EMOTIONAL SUPPORT ANIMAL.
SAID TO BORROW MONEY FROM A
FAMILY MEMBER TO PAY FOR HER NEW
AT OTHER VETERANS TO NOT HAVE
THAT OPTION.
THIS BILL OPENS THE DOOR FOR SO
MANY VETERANS SEEKING
COMPANIONSHIP AND EMOTIONAL.
SB TWO FOUR FIVE RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE BMP
COMMITTEE AND HAS EARNED FIVE
CARS AND A LOT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THIS.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IS AN
OUTSOURCED RUNNING LATE -- WHO'S
ON THE HAVE THE HELPFULNESS OF
SHIP BETTER AND SERVICE AGENCIES
AND THEN WE HAVE SEAT.
WE'VE ON BEHALF OF NUMEROUS
VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
THE AMERICAN GI FORUM OF
CALIFORNIA AND CAL STATE MATTERS.
REMEMBER MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS --
MY CLIENTS REPRESENTING AMERICAN
LEGION DEPARTMENT OF ALIFORNIA
AMERICAN GI FORM OF CALIFORNIA
AMVETS DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE MANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL.
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA AND THE VIETNAM
VETERANS OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL'S ALL IN SUPPORT
OF THIS LEGISLATION.
AS A VETERAN WITH PTSD.
I FOUND A NEW WORLD OF COMFORT
HAVING A NOT A SERVICE DOG.
EVEN THOUGH I DO NOT NEED A
SERVICE DOG.
DUE TO MY DISABILITIES I LOVE MY
COMPANION DOG SHE HAS ALWAYS
BEEN THERE FOR ME.
IN CAN CALM ME DOWN SHE WAKES ME
UP IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT
WHEN I'M HAVING NIGHTMARES.
AND JUST KNOWS WHAT I'M OVERALL
HAVING A BAD DAY AND IS THERE TO
COME. ONE OF THE BEST THINGS
THAT I FOUND MY YEAH.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ALEX TOURISM
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES I
WOULD JUST ACT ECHO MISTER
REED'S COMMENTS -- THE SUPPORT
THAT THESE ANIMALS PROVIDE TO
VETERANS IS IMMEASURABLE THERE'S
A GROWING.
BASELINE OF SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
TO SUPPORT THE BENEFITS THAT IT
OFFERS THESE VETERANS -- WOULD
URGE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANY OTHER COME.
NOW LET ME OPEN UP THE QUESTIONS
TO THE FOR MY FELLOW --
COLLEAGUES.
SENATOR RICHARD ROTH.
I WILL BE UP.
I AM A LITTLE OF TERM.
THE S. TO THE STANDARDS USED%
QUALIFY TO HAVE THE WORD VETERAN
ADDED TO THE DRIVER'S LICENSE
THERE WERE SOME ISSUES.
OF A FEW MONTHS AGO AS SOON AS A
BEEN RESOLVED CALVET I JUST AS
TAKE A LOOK AT IT TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WHATEVER THE STANDARDS ARE THAT
THEY'RE NOT -- OVERLY
RESTRICTIVE AND ELIMINATE THE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME
VETERANS -- TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
YOUR BILL AND THEN THE OTHER
POINT I WOULD MAKE IS OF SOME OF
US DON'T HAVE VETERAN.
ID CARD BUT HAVE OTHER
GOVERNMENT ISSUED.
CARDS THAT CLEARLY INDICATE THAT
WERE VETERAN SO -- IT WOULD MAKE
IT A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO UTILIZE
THIS UNLESS WE WANT TO GO DOWN.
THE LOCAL -- CVS SO WHEN IT THE
LETTER AND THEN GO TO THE DMV.
HAVE ANOTHER RIGHT DRIVER'S
LICENSE ISSUE SO.
YOU MIGHT BE ABLE AS YOU MOVE
THROUGH THIS TO JUST ADDRESS
THAT.
WITH A SIMPLE SET.
BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE ABILITY
OF CORPORATE POINT.
THANKS VERY MUCH REATER.
THANK YOU FOR MOVING THE BILL --
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS -- AND IS THERE ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
COME UP THE BEST MICROPHONE OF
SPORT.
ANY WHEN IN OPPOSITION THE BILL
[inaudible]
SEE NONE.
THEN I WOULD GO AHEAD AND ENTER
CHIANG LESIA YOUR CLOSING
REMARKS.
I HAD JUST.
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
AND THE OTHER SECRETARY FOR YOU --
NOW THAT WE'VE GOT WE'RE GOING
TO SEND THIS ON AND WE'RE GONNA
MOVE THE BILL ON WITH YOU WITH
THE BOAT.
WE'LL SEND IT ON TO
APPROPRIATIONS SO.
I CAN HAVE THE ROLL CALL.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FIVE DO
YOU HAVE TO FIRST [inaudible]
ASIANS.
ARCHULETA YES HI I BROUGH
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
I NUMBER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
WELL I WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN WE'VE GOT A FEW THAT IT
WILL BRING IN.
THE COMPLETE THE ROLE BUT IT
WILL PASS IT ON TO APPROACH.
SOMEONE.
YOU'RE.
ALL OF THAT WE WERE
[inaudible]
IN THE THE NEXT -- ONE HIS S.
SENATE BILL FIVE HUNDRED MIKE
MORRELL.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON A GOOD
AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU GUYS READY.
YOU'RE READY OKAY I'M READY.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON.
SB.
FIVE HUNDRED IS A PLAN TO ACCEPT
YOUR AB TO EXPAND CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR STATES --
RETURNING.
THIS DISABLED VETERANS THE BILL
WOULD CREATE A GRADUATE LEVEL
EDUCATION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM FOR
DISABLED VETS.
DURAN ABLE TO GET THE SAME AID
FEDERAL LEVEL.
SB FIVE HUNDRED AS THE MODEL
AFTER THE FEDERAL GI BILL AS
WELL AS A SIMILAR.
LOCATION VALIDATION PROGRAM THAT
IS OFFERED TO SOME DISABLED
VETERANS.
CURRENTLYDISABLED VETERANS MAY
BE ENTITLED TO THE FEDERAL.
CATION ALL -- PROGRAM BUT LACKS.
TRANSPARENCY AND QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS MAY BE DENIED
BENEFITS WITH LITTLE TO NO
EXPLANATIONS.
SO WE WANT ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA
VETERANS ARE DISABLED VETERANS
ARE NOT THE NIGHT.
OF THEIR BENEFITS AND CREATIVE
PROGRAM HERE.
ARE THE CIVILIAN JOB MARKET IS
BECOMING MORE MORE COMPETITIVE
AS I THINK WE ALL KNOW.
AND HAVING A BACHELORS DEGREE
SOMETIMES IS NOT ALWAYS ENOUGH
FOR THE ENTRY LEVEL POSITIONS SO
WE KNOW THAT PATRONS.
ARE TYPICALLY HARD WORKING
PROFESSIONAL LEADERS BUT DO NOT
ALWAYS STAND OUT ON APPLICATIONS
LIKE VETERANS FROM PAST
GENERATIONS.
SO BY CREATING A PATH FOR THE
STUDENTS TO STRIVE AND THRIVE
FOR THEIR MASTER'S DEGREE WE
WILL BE INVESTING.
IN THEIR FUTURES AND OF COURSE
THE FEATURE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
STRENGTHENING OUR WORKFORCE SO
IT'S NO SECRET.
THAT WHEN VETERANS RETURN OF THE
WORK FORCE FROM THE SERVICE IT
YIELDS POSITIVE RESULTS AND SO
WITH ME TODAY AS MY FRIEND ON
BEHALF OF THIS BILL.
AND CONSTITUENT RICHARD ABOUT
THE HOUSE FROM THE DISABLED
AMERICAN VETERANS [inaudible]
SO SPEECH.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN ARCHULETA
FOR THE SOME TO SPEAK ON SB --
FIVE HUNDRED AGAIN MY NAME'S
RICHARD VALDEZ AND I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
DISABLED AMERICAN VETERANS
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA I'M ALSO A
VIETNAM VETERAN.
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN SIXTY EIGHT
AN IDEA I UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY
WHAT.
WITH THIS BILL WILL DO FOR
DISABLED VETERANS AT A HOSPITAL
ALL LAW AVENUES OF APPROACH IN
TERMS OF GETTING AN ADVANCED
DEGREE.
I WAS UP FORTUNATE I WORK FOR A
COMPANY THAT.
PAID FOR MY AREA OF FOR ME TO
FINISH MY DEGREE AFTER RIGHT
EXHAUSTED.
ALL MY YEAH THAT AFFECTS.
AND OUT WHEN THEY ASKED ME TO
TAKE ON A AN ADDITIONAL JOBS.
AND CLASSIFIED ENVIRONMENT.
I DIDN'T HAVE THE SKILLS.
I FELT TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT JOB
THEY SENT ME TO UCLA FOR TWO
YEAR PROGRAM IN ORDER TO DEVELOP
THAT.
SO I CAN SEE THE VALUE.
SB FIVE HUNDRED AND HELPING OUR
VETERANS HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I THINK.
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE THING TO DO
FOR VETERANS I WANT TO THANK
SENATOR MORALE FOR COMING UP
WITH THE SMELL.
THANK YOU SIR.
IS THERE ANYONE.
HERE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
NOT.
IS YOUR ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THE STATE YOUR NAME -- MY
NUMBER'S WE CAN ALL YOUR YOU
PLATE.
THE MEMBERS AT BUT I MEAN CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS SET THREE
WITH THREE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS --
AMERICANS YOU HAVE FOR A
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S THE PART
IN A CALIFORNIA MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
IN THE VIETNAM VICTOR VETERANS
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL ON TO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS ALEX
TOWARDS THE STRATEGIES THREE
SIXTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
VETERANS SERVICE AGENCIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND I HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
AND ONE SECOND.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE HAD MOTION
THE PORCH OR TO BUILD -- IN --
THE STATE.
SO CENTER MORALE.
SHE THE BILL WAS PASSED
[inaudible]
IN.
YOU HAVE YOUR CLOSING REMARKS
YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE FOR THIS. FOR THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO HAVE SERVED IN
[inaudible]
PROTECT THEIR HADN'T CALL ROOM.
SENATE BILL FIVE HUNDRED DO PATH
[inaudible]
DURATION [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
HI ACTUALLY I WROTE.
AYE AUTO.
I NIELSEN.
ROTH ROTH AYE NUMBER.
WELL I WILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE BILL DOES PASS WILL IN A
HOLD OVER.
THE OTHER COUPLE VOTE REGULATION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
PLEDGE THE BENCH.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELCOME HOME --IN THE NOW WE'LL
GO ON TO THE NEXT ITEM.
I AM NEXT FIVE OH ONE MELISSA
DAUGHTER WOULD YOU STEP DOWN AND
TAKE YOUR POSITION AT THE DESK
.
UNDER YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I LIKE TO START OFF BY SEVENTEEN
OF COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS OFFERED
BY THE COMMITTEE WHICH WOULD
CLARIFY THE USAGE CONDITIONS OF
THE READ THE ARMORY.
AND WHICH ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY
AND DRAFT AMENDMENT FORM.
AND WILL BE TAKEN AND
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK OUR CHAIR
AND RUNNING.
ABOUT DEAL WITH THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH OUR OFFICE ON
THESE IMPORTANT AND AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL FIVE A ONE WILL HELP
A SMALL COMMUNITY IN THE
SOUTHERN CENTRAL VALLEY BETWEEN
AN ARMORY THAT WILL HELP SERVE
OUR VETERANS IN THE REGION.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THE
READ LEE AREA.
VETERANS HAVE OPERATED B. R.
ARMORY FOR VARIOUS EVENTS
INCLUDING VETERAN SERVICES.
THE REALLY AREA VETS WORK TO
HELP RETURNING VETERANS WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
THROUGH RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
WORKING WITH CONDITIONS.
LIKE THE JOE LOST MEMORIAL
FOUNDATION TO PROVIDE RESOURCES.
FOOD AND ASSISTANCE WITH MEDICAL
COST ABOUT IT VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE CITY OF RIDLEY IS INVESTED
IN MAKING SURE THE ARMORY STAYS
IN THE COMMUNITY FOR PURPOSES OF
SERVING OUR VETERANS.
AND ALREADY WORKS TO MAINTAIN
THE ARMORY INCLUDING THE LAWN
AND LANDSCAPE BEING I WORKS OF
NONPROFIT ENTITY STRUCTURE
VETERANS SERVICES ARE ACCESSIBLE
TO VETERANS IN THE REGION.
HOWEVER WHILE THE ROOM RIDLEY
ARMORY WAS AUTHORIZED FOR CELL
BY A. B. THIRTY TO FIFTY ONE THE
SALE OF THE ARMORY PARCEL HAS
BEEN POSTPONED.
AND THE CITY OF RIDLEY HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH THE STATE TO TRY TO
KEEP THE ARMORY.
THE REALLY ARMORY SERVES AS A
CRITICAL ACCESS POINT VETERANS
IN THE RIDLEY AND SURROUNDING
REGION.
OFTEN HAVE.
HAVE TO A DIFFICULT TIME
ACCEPTING A NEARBY AMERICAN
LEGION POSTER NEARBY VETERANS.
SERVANT SERVING ORGANIZATION.
FOR EXAMPLE THE NEAREST VETERANS
MEMORIAL DISTRICT IS IN OFFICE
OVER TWO HOURS AWAY BY PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION.
AND FORTY MINUTES AWAY BY OUR SB
FIVE ALL ONE WOULD HELP ENSURE
THAT OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
VERY AND VETERANS ALSO HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE CRITICAL
SERVICES.
AND I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY
ON THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE WITH
ME TODAY I HAVE.
ALL THE WELL WITH THE CITY OF
RIDLEY AND AFTER A JEWEL AT THE
TENT -- THE AMERICAN LEGION POST
[inaudible]
THIRTY FIVE MY TURN.
WELL I AM ANTHONY JEWEL OF THE
AMERICAN LEGION POST THIRTY FIVE
FRESNO COUNTY COMMUNITY OF READ
LEE CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TODAY TO ENCOURAGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR OUR VETERANS
CONTINUED USE OF OUR FORMER
NATIONAL GUARD ARMORY.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT OUR
VETERANS HAVE BEEN EXCELLENT
STEWARDS OF THE PROPERTY NOT
ONLY HAVE WE PROVIDED CUSTODIAL
CARE.
BUT WE'VE MADE IMPROVEMENTS SUCH
AS REMODELING THE KITCHEN
APPLIANCES AND ALSO CONVERTING.
THE MEN SHOWER AREA INTO A
WOMEN'S ADA COMPLIANT Là TRAIN.
WE DID THESE IMPROVEMENTS AT OUR
COST.
OUR AREA VETERANS HAVE REGARDED
THE ARMORY AS COMMUNITY PROPERTY.
AND AS SUCH WE HAVE SHARED THE
PROPERTY BY HOSTING SCHOOL
DISTRICT EVENTS OR CIVIC EVENTS
SUCH AS THE RECENT KOREAN
VISITORS DELEGATION.
WELL THERE HAVE BEEN CELEBRATE
TORY OCCASIONS OF ALSO BEEN
THOSE OF FINAL RESPECT FOR THE
FAMILIES OF OUR FALLEN VETERANS.
FINANCIALLY.
MANY OF THOSE FAMILIES MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO AFFORD A
RECEPTION ALL.
AT THE ARMORY NOT BEEN AVAILABLE.
MANY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES HAVE
THE BENEFIT OF A SUSTAINED.
HOME GUARD OR NATIONAL GUARD. TO
ASSIST IN EMERGENCIES OR
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS.
THAT ABSENCE INOUR COMMUNITY
CAN BE PARTIALLY RESTORED BY AND
JOINING THE CITY OF READ LIKE.
A SHARE THE ARMORY WITH THE
VETERANS AS AN EMERGENCY
FACILITY.
THE PROPERTY AND THE FACILITY
HAVE AND CAN PROVIDE UNIQUE
POTENTIAL LOGISTICAL SUPPORT.
THE BUILDING FLOOR IS AT GRADE.
AND WITH A FOURTEEN BY FOURTEEN
ROLL UP DOOR.
TRANSFER.
OF EMERGENCY SUPPLIES.
EMERGENCY ELECTRICAL SERVICE CAN
BE EASILY ACCESSED WITH A SMALL
MODIFICATION TO PROVIDE AN
EXTERNAL.
ELECTRICAL GENERATOR FOR SUPPORT.
IN SUMMARY WE HOPE THAT YOU CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT THAT
THE RIDLEY ARMORY IS TO OUR
VETERANS AND TO OUR COMMUNITY.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU SENATORS I AM THE
COALS EVEN ON THE CITY MANAGER
FOR THE CITY OF BRIEFLY AND I'D
LIKE TO EXPLAIN TO YOU THAT THE
CITY OF RIDLEY IS.
A CITY OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
POPULATION VERY SMALL WORLD
BASED AGRICULTURAL BASED
COMMUNITY.
WERE 76% LOW INCOME HISPANIC
POPULATION.
SO THE VETERANS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
WERE BORN IN POVERTY BASICALLY
THEY SERVE THEIR COUNTRY THEY
COME BACK THAT DOESN'T MEAN THEY
EXIT POVERTY AND WHAT HAS
HAPPENED OVER THE COURSE OF THE
PAST DECADE IS THEY'VE GOTTEN
TOGETHER.
FORM TO THEIR OWN NONPROFIT
ENTITY NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
CITY I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY
THEY'VE DONE THIS ON THEIR OWN
AND FOR OVER A DECADE.
OF USE THAT FACILITY FOR
FUNDRAISING SO THAT EVERY FUNDS
ALL THE FUNDS THEY RAISE.
PROVIDE VETERANS SERVICES THEY
HAVEN'T ASKED THE CITY FOR A
DIME THEY'VE DONE THIS ON THEIR
OWN THE ONLY SUPPORT THE CITY
HAS BEEN ABLE TO GIVE THEM IS.
TOO LONG FOR THEM.
AND SO RIGHT NOW THEY'RE IN A
STATE OF FRANKLY PANIC BECAUSE
THEY'VE PROVIDED SERVICES FOR SO
LONG.
IN THE REGION WHERE WE ARE WE
ARE A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY WE
ARE A DRAW THE ARMORY IS A DRAW
FOR VETERANS NOT JUST WITHIN
RIDLEY.
I WOULD SAY PROBABLY IN A FIFTY
MILE SURROUNDING AREA AND THESE
VETERANS KNOW THEY AN GO TO THE
ARMORY FOR SERVICES -- WE DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE NATIONAL GUARD
STRATEGY FOR NEW ARMORIES I
THINK IT'S A BRILLIANT STRATEGY --
AND AS A SURPLUS OFF THE
ARMORIES.
WE UNDERSTAND COMPLETELY THE
DIFFERENCE HERE IN REALLY IS
THAT OUR ARMY HAS BEEN IN USE BY
VETERANS FOR VETERANS.
THAT'S DISTINCTLY DIFFERENT THAN
THESE OTHER ARMORIES THAT HAVE
BEEN VACANT.
THE OTHER DIFFERENCE IS.
THE OTHER ARM RESERVING SURPLUS
OFFERING COMMUNITIES OF WE WE
TALK TO THE NATIONAL GUARD ABOUT
THE ONE THEY JUST SOLD IN SANTA
BARBARA -- OVER MILLION DOLLARS
IN READ LEAVE BECAUSE WERE
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND POPULATION
THAT IS LOW INCOME -- POVERTY
POCKET AN UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF
ALMOST 20%.
WE CANNOT.
COME UP WITH THE HALF MILLION
DOLLARS THAT THEY WANT FOR THIS
PROP.
AND SO GRACIOUSLY SENATOR
D'AMATO HAS RUN SB FIVE A ONE ON
BEHALF OF THE REALLY AREA
VETERANS.
AND I'M HERE TO SAY THAT WE
SUPPORT THE READ THE AREA
VETERANS THE CITY DOES.
IN AS MANY WAYS AS WE CAN --
WE'RE WE'RE HERE TO LET YOU KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SUCH GREAT
STEWARDS OF THE STATE'S PROPERTY
THEY HAVE REMODELED ON THEIR OWN
THEY HAVE RAISE MONEY ON THEIR
OWN.
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO THE VETS -- I
UNDERSTAND THE WERE AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL AND WE COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THOSE AMENDMENTS THE
CITY.
SUPPORTS WHAT THE REALLY AREA
VETERANS WANT TO DO IN TERMS OF
INSTALLING A TRACK SYSTEMS
EVERYTHING THEY'VE DONE OVER THE
COURSE OF THE PAST DECADE
THEY'VE BEEN IN A BUILDING THAT
IS NOT ADA COMPLIANT AND HAS NO
AIR CONDITIONING OF EATING.
AND THEY'VE STILL BEEN ABLE TO
MAKE.
LEMONADE OUT OF LEMONS
ESSENTIALLY.
AND SO WE ARE A SUBSTANTIALLY
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY AND YOU WILL
FIND THESE OTHER ARMORIES.
AND WE JUST PUT WOULD PLEAD WITH
YOU TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
VETERANS.
HAVE TROUBLE BECAUSE WE ARE LOW
INCOME COMMUNITY HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING UP TO FRESNO FOR
SERVICES.
AND WE HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
THEY HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN PULLING THOSE SERVICES
DOWNTURN BRIEFLY.
SO THAT SURROUNDING COMMUNITY
VETERANS AND ACCESS SERVICES
THEY WOULDN'T OTHERWISE BE ABLE
TO ACCESS SO WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON SENATOR.
THIS BILL.
YEAH. ONE SENATOR IS YOUR ANY
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD [inaudible]
ANYONE -- IS IN THE IS THERE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SET THREE WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS
REPRESENTING NATIONAL GUARD
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SENATE ROTH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
FIRST LET ME GO.
MAKE A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
BILL I OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT.
TO SUPPORTING VETERANS BOTH IN-RURAL AREAS AND FRANKLY -- OUR
STATE AND NATION [inaudible]
THE RESERVE FREEDOM FOR US AND
THEY DESERVE THE APPROPRIATE
ACTION FROM US WHEN WHEN THEY
NEED HELP.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS I'VE
SPENT -- ABOUT SIX I SPENT SIX
YEARS ACTUALLY IS THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR CHAIR WHICH
DEALT WITH ARMORIES.
OUR RESEARCH SURPLUS SINGER
MARIE DISPOSITION AND THE REST
INCLUDING OUR WORRY [inaudible]
RENOVATION -- AND MY CONCERNS
HAVE TO DO WITH THAT A MAYES YOU
MAY KNOW.
WE HAVE ABOUT EIGHTY ARMORIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
IN NEED OF RENOVATION MANY OF
THESE WERE BUILT IN THE FORTIES
AND THE FIFTIES WHEN.
OF FEMALES WERE NOT SERVING IN
THE NATIONAL GUARD FOR THE MOST
PART ONE NOW THEY ARE -- AND
MOST OF THESE ARE SOLDIERS --
THEIR FIELD UNITS.
MANY OF THOSE ARMORIES HAVE NO
FEMALE RESTROOMS ARE CHANGING
FACILITY.
SO WHEN WE A SURPLUS ARMORIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HISTORICALLY WE HAVE TOLD THEM
THAT SOME PRICE OF THE STATUTE
SAYS MARKET PRICE BUT WE KNOW
THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES AND MILITARY DEPARTMENT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE FINANCIAL.
CIRCUMSTANCES OF THE LOCAL
ENTITY THAT TRYING TO ACQUIRE
THEM.
AND MANY OF THEM ARE NOT IN
SANTA BARBARA -- BROLLY COMES TO
MIND IT'S THAT ARE SIMILARLY
SITUATED I'M SURE THE CITY OF
RIDLEY.
SO WHEN THESE ARMORIES ARE SOLD
THE PROCEEDS ARE PUT INTO WHAT'S
CALLED AN ARMORY FUND AND AN
ARMORY FUND IS USED.
WITH OTHER FUNDS. TO REMODEL
THESE ARMORIES AROUND THE STATE
AND IT'S ABOUT A FOUR FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR TAB -- REMODEL
GIVE OR TAKE [inaudible]
THE THERE'S SOME SPLITTING OF
THE ARMORY COST WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STATE AND FEDS BUT
I'M CONCERNED IF WE STARTA
PRACTICE OF OF NOT CAPTURING AT
LEAST SOME.
THE MONEY OUT OF THE DISPOSITION
OF OUR WORRIES THAT WE MAY.
INTERFERE WITH OUR ABILITY TO
REMODEL THE ARMORIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY UTILIZED BY ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING.
MEN AND WOMEN IN UNIFORM.
NOT TO DIMINISH THE NEED THAT WE
HAVE TO SUPPORT VETERANS BUT WE
NEED TO BALANCE.
BUT WE DO SO THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING SERVICES FRANK TO BOTH.
COMPONENTS SO HAVING SAID ALL
THAT I'VE MADE THE MOTION AND
FIRMLY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I NOTED THE AMENDMENTS PROVIDE
OF TRANSFERRED TO THE CITY OF
RIDLEY AFTER FIVE YEARS.
EARLY AT NO COST.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
AND NEGOTIATED THE PRICE DOWN TO
WAS SOMEWHERE AROUND
200-100-02200 FIFTY THOUSAND FOR
THE ARMORY IF I'M WRONG MAYBE
BECAUSE I'M NOT THE NEGOTIATIONS --
AND MAYBE THAT'S TOO MUCH AND I
UNDERSTAND SMALL CITIES ARE
FINANCIALLY CHALLENGED ACTUALLY
ALL CITIES ARE FINANCIALLY
CHALLENGED IN THE STATE LARGELY
DUE TO WHAT WE DO HOME UP HERE.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT IF WE ARE
GOING TO START PRACTICE.
I'M ASKING THE AUTHOR TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THIS.
THEN MAYBE AS PART OF THIS WE
SHOULD DEFINE A HARDSHIP
STANDARD THAT WE CAN APPLY TO
SMALL.
A RURAL COMMUNITIES SO WE'RE NOT
DEALING WITH THESE REQUESTS ON A
PIECEMEAL BASIS BECAUSE WE WILL
GET MORE.
BUT RATHER WE'RE DEALING WITH
THEM ON A ON THE ON THE SAME
BASIS ONCE WE APPLY CENTER
HARDSHIPS STANDARD AND THEN
APPLY TO MUNICIPALITIES IT'S
SIMPLY CANNOT PAY.
PERHAPS ANYTHING FOR THE ARMORY.
THEY BADLY NEED IN ORDER THIS
BOARD ARE VOTE.
SO WHAT CENTER THAT'S MY SEAT
THE REQUESTED TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT I REITERATE MY REITERATE MY
MOTION TO STRUCTURE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
MOTION.
AND YOUR COMMENT [inaudible]
SENATOR.
NOT THE AUTHORITY OF MY
COLLEAGUE.
BUT I HAVE REPRESENTED MANY.
ARMOR.
AND PUTTING ONE NEARLY NEXT DOOR.
MY COLLEAGUE THE AUTHOR.
AND I CAME HOME TOWN.
THERE IS THE ARMY THERE.
TO I DON'T KNOW WHAT STATUS
SENATOR BUT I'M.
THEY'VE BEEN STRUGGLING AND THEY
HAVE BEEN IN MY OPINION.
THIS BILL DECADE.
THEY HAVE.
NOT WITHSTANDING THE SUPPORT OF
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL NEWS
AND VETERANS ORGANIZATIONS.
KEEP THEM UP.
SO IT IS A CHALLENGE AND I
CERTAINLY WILL ATTEST.
THE THE MAYOR.
THE MANAGER THE MANAGERS OF
COMMENTS ABOUT COMMUNITY AND AND
THE DIFFICULTIES OF THE VALLEY
RIGHT NOW.
AND IT DOES SERVE A NOBLE.
ORDER SUPPORTING THE BILL.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
LET ME GIVE YOU MY COMMENTS.
BUT ONE CHAU SORRY.
YES SENATOR.
AND AS THE ONLY FEMALE VETERAN
SERVING ON THE STATE SENATE ALL
RIGHT ON THE AUTHOR I MEAN WE
NEED -- WE SHARE KERN COUNTY
SIDE THAT -- ON THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION OF THE SPRING IT
TODAY.
I DID HAVE ONE QUESTION BECAUSE
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW IT
TRANSITIONS AND IF IT GOES FROM
THE STATE RIGHT NOW THE STATE
DOESN'T ANY.
TAXES RIGHT ON THE PROPERTY IF
IT GOES TO AND THE VETERANS
COMMUNITY DOES IT.
DEBATE IN YOU GUYS ARE GONNA
FIGURE THAT OUT.
I BELIEVE IN THE BILL IS THE
PROPERTY TRANSFER OKAY WE WE GET
FROM THE FANS BURKE.
BUT WE WOULD THEN.
LISA THE CENTRALLY AT NO COST TO
THE RIVER AREA BATS THEY HAVE
DEALT WITH THIS ARMORY SO WELL
OVER THE PAST DECADE WE DON'T
WANT TO GET INVOLVED IN THEIR
BUSINESS THERE THEY'VE BEEN
DOING THERE.
VERY WELL GREAT OKAY I'M JUST
CURIOUS ABOUT THE TAX STRUCTURE
I WASN'T SURE IF THAT HAD BEEN
ADDRESSED AND SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS THAT.
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER GROW YES ONE
MORE POINT ON THAT IN AND IT.
THIS BILL MAY NOT BE THE TARGET
OF OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE THINGS
THAT.
MIGHT.
ALEXANDER OFFICE TO GASP WHICH
NEED TO BE DONE.
IT MAY OR MAY NOT BE THE WE HAVE
HOPE IS THIS MAY REQUIRE A
LITTLE BIT A STUDY.
CERTAINLY THE CRITERIA MAYBE FOR
A OF FRESH COMMUNITY OR OR A
HARDSHIP CIRCUMSTANCE.
BUT MAYBE JUST SOME NON
PRESIDENTIAL LANGUAGE COULD BE
INSERTED HERE.
IN IN THE BILL THIS IS NOT A
PRECEDENT OBLIGING.
FUTURE DECISION WHICH WE CAN'T
DO ANYWAY.
BUT THAT OFTEN IS PUT IN BILLS
INCLUDING ONE THIS VERY DAY IN
ANOTHER COMMITTEE FOR ANOTHER
PURPOSE BUT NOT NOT PRESIDENTIAL
THAT MIGHT HAMPER WE'RE NOT.
OBLIGING ANYBODY IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU IF I MAY COMMENT.
I I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT I
THINK -- EVERY EVERY BILL -- IS
AN INDIVIDUAL -- IN THIS
PARTICULAR SITUATION THIS IS AN
INDIVIDUAL -- SITUATION.
WHERE WE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT
THAT VETERANS SHOULD YOUR
COMMUNITY IN YOUR CITY?
I'VE WORKED SO HARD OVER THE
YEARS TO COME BACK AND SERVE OUR
GREAT COUNTRY.
AND THIS IS OUR WAY OF SAYING
THANK YOU OBVIOUSLY.
BUT WITH THAT THANK YOU COMES
CONDITION THAT CONDITION AS THAT
YOU MAINTAIN IT. FIVE YEARS YOU
IMPROVE IT TO MAINTAIN IT AND IT
IS ALWAYS TO BE FOR THE USE OF
VETERANS.
THE PURPOSE OF VETERANS -- AND
NOT NECESSARILY GIVEN TO THE
AMERICAN LEGION OR THAT THEY
WERE THE GI FORM THE V. F. W. OR
ANY PARTICULAR ENTITY.
BUT IT IS SOLELY FOR THE
UMBRELLA OF ALL BETTER.
AND REGARDLESS OF BRANCHES OF
SERVICE.
THE ARMY THE NAVY THE AIRFORCE
RECORD THE COAST GUARD EMERGING
BRAINS TO BE TREATED FAIRLY AND
EQUITABLY WOMEN.
WHO SERVED OUR GREAT COUNTRY?
SO I A A POINT THIS OUT TO YOU
CITY MANAGER.
THAT YOU HAVE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT IT DOESN'T BELONG TO ONE
UNIT BLOCKS ALL UNIT DOESN'T
BELONG -- TO ONE PARTICULAR
ENTITY IN YOUR COMMUNITY.
ALL THE COMMUNITY THIS IS VERY
VERY UNUSUAL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO KNOWLEDGE JUST
GIVE YOU.
THE USE FOR THE FIVE YEARS.
AND THEN TO COME BACK AND SAY IF
YOU MET THOSE OBLIGATIONS THEN
IT WILL GO TO YOUR CITY -- TO BE
VERY CAREFUL.
pYOUR OWN CITY.
IN REFERENCE TO THE CONDITION TO
USE THE THE MAINTENANCE.
THE EXTERIOR THE INTERIOR -- AS
WE HAD MENTIONED THE AIR
CONDITIONING HEATING AND SHOW ON
SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT.
AND ANYTIME A BETTER NEEDS HELP
IT SHOULD COME RIGHT TO THAT
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER.
AND I THINK THAT SHOULD BE THE
VETERANS RESOURCE CENTER OF YOUR
CITY.
AND THE KNOWLEDGE IT WITH PRIDE
BECAUSE IT IS REFLECTIVE OF THE
MEN AND WOMEN WHO SERVED IN YOUR
GREAT CITY SO WITH THAT.
SENATOR COULD NOT -- I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE YOU DUING THIS
STANDING UP FOR YOUR COMMUNITY
AS YOU HAVE.
AND I'LL GO AHEAD AND LET YOU
CLOSE.
THANK YOU -- I RESPECTFULLY
ASPIRIN I WILL [inaudible]
AND THE ROLE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH ONE DO PATH
BUT FIRST RIVER -- RULE
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
HI.
I WROTE.
AYE AUTO I DON'T I NIELSEN.
I ROTH.
I AMBER.
WILK.
WELL I IT WILL HOLD THE ROAST
BEEF REMAINING VOTE TO
GRADUATION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS.
AS WE WAIT.
FOR NEXT ONE UP.
SENATORS STEVE GLAZER.
CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE YOU HAVE IS J. R.
[inaudible]
SEVEN AND YOU HAVE THE FLOOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR ARCHULETA. NINE
MEMBERS GREAT TO BE WITH YOU TO
TALK ABOUT AN ISSUE THAT.
IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
HISTORY.
OF BOTH IN CALIFORNIA AND ACOSTA
AND OF COURSE FOR OUR NATION.
BUT THIS RESOLUTION -- URGES
CONGRESS. TO HONOR MERRILL'S
MARAUDERS A GROUP OF WORLD WAR
TWO HEROES IN A LARGELY
FORGOTTEN CHAPTER.
OF THAT GREAT -- CONTEST
FOURTEEN OF THE ORIGINAL
VOLUNTEERS AND THERE WERE THREE
THOUSAND ARE STILL WITH US.
ALL IN THEIR NINETIES.
THIS RESOLUTION WOULD URGE
CONGRESS TO BESTOW THE
CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL.
ON THESE BRAVE MEN.
NOW THAT BIT OF HISTORY THAT I
KNOW IS CONTAINED IN THE
RESOLUTION BUT LET ME SUMMARIZE
PART OF IT.
MERRILL'S MARAUDERS WAS THE
UNITED STATES ARMY SPECIAL
OPERATIONS UNIT.
WHICH BECAME FAMOUS FOR THE
DANGEROUS MISSION.
THEY CONDUCTED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES IN THE JUNGLE OF BURMA.
AMONG THE THREE THOUSAND
AMERICAN SOLDIERS WHO
VOLUNTEERED FOR THIS MISSION.
FIFTEEN ETHNIC GROUPS FROM EVERY
STATE REPRESENTED.
INCLUDING.
DEATH MARCH SURVIVORS NI SE
INTERPRETERS AND NATIVE AMERICAN
CODE TALKERS.
SOME EVEN JOIN THE GROUP FROM
THE STOCK GATES.
NICKNAMED THE DEAD END KIDS WERE
VOLUNTEERING.
EARNED THEIR FREEDOM. ONE OF THE
MAJOR STAGING GROUNDS FOR THIS
MISSION WAS IN PITTSBURGH IN MY
DISTRICT FROM CAMP STONE.
RECENTLY ONE OF THE LAST
SURVIVORS PLACED A WREATH AT
CAMP STONEMAN MEMORIAL.
AT THE PITTSBURGH HISTORICAL
MUSEUM TO COMMEMORATE THE
SEVENTY FIFTH ANNIVERSARY.
OF THE NINETEEN FORTY FOUR
MERRITT MERRILL'S MARAUDERS
MISSION.
ASK YOU TODAY TO JOIN ME IN
HONORING THESE MEN AND ASKING
CONGRESS TOOK KNOWLEDGE.
THERE WAS.
THAT I APPRECIATE YOUR FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION MISTER CHAIR.
WE HAVE MOVED THE BILL IS THERE
ANYONE OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THIS BILL -- IT WILL SUPPORT
THIS BILL YOU'RE WELCOME TO STEP
UP TO THE MIKE.
OKAY CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SET THREE WITH READ GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS.
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN GI
FORM OF CALIFORNIA EMERICA
LEGION DEPARTMENT OF CALIFORNIA.
AMVETS DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION A COUNTY
VETERANS SERVICE OFFICERS
CALIFORNIA STATE COMMANDERS
VETERANS COUNCIL MILITARY
OFFICERS ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF CHAPTERS
NATIONAL GUARD ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE VIETNAM
VETERANS.
OF AMERICA CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL ON SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- CENTER HERE IN THE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS [inaudible]
YES SIR.
OKAY I'D LIKE.
TO COMMENT.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO POINT OUT.
THAT THE THIS UNIT. FOR MY
UNDERSTAND IS AN OFF SHOOT THAT.
IT ORIGINATED FROM ALL THE
VOLUNTEERS WHO COME TOGETHER
SURE OF OUR GREAT COUNTRY ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE CALL OF DUTY.
AND WHAT THEY WERE ABLE TO
ACCOMPLISH IN WORLD WAR TWO WAS
AMAZING.
AND THAT LED US TO OUR RANGERS
AND OUR SPECIAL FORCES AND MEN
AND WOMEN WHO TODAY OR SERVING
IN THESE -- REMOTE PLACES A
WORLD AND THIS WAS AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT HISTORY CAN SHOW US.
AND WOULD YOU ONCE AGAIN SENATOR
TELL US THE NUMBER OF WORLD WAR
TWO VETERANS WHO SERVED THAT
UNIT THAT ARE STILL WITH US.
CURRENTLY -- ONLY FOURTEEN OF
THE ORIGINAL THREE THOUSAND
VOLUNTEERS ARE STILL WITH US ALL
FOR SUPPORTING TNCS.
SO WITH THAT I AM HONORED TO SAY
THAT -- I THINK WE'RE ALL IN
SUPPORT. FOR THEIR SERVICE SO I
WOULD LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND
CONGRATULATE YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
AND I THINK WE'RE READY TO CALL
THE ROSTER CHAIRMAN OF MY
CLOTHES OKAY RIGHT ONE REFERENCE
A U. S. ARMY RANGER TOM STILL
WAS EXPECTED TO BE WITH US TODAY.
I UNFORTUNATELY.
TRAFFIC HAS GOTTEN IN THE WAY OF
ARRIVING IN TIME BUT I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT.
THAT HE'S A RANGER.
AND AS YOU NOTED THAT THE
RANGERS HAVE A PATCH.
THAT'S THE MERYL MARAUDERS PATCH
ON THEIR UNIFORM IN HONOR OF
THAT.
JUST THAT MISSION THAT THEY
UNDERTOOK WITH THAT THANK YOU.
FEDERATION MAY I BECAUSE THAT
RANGERS NOT IN THE HOUSE MAY I
IT'S SYMBOLICALLY TELL YOU THAT
MY SON MATTHEW ARCHULETA IS A
RANGER AND I'LL TAKE THAT YEAH
AND IT TO YOU OF THAT THAT'S
VERY NICE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY THE ROPE.
SJR SEVEN TO BE ADOPTED
ARCHULETA.
HI.
I GREW.
RICARDO.
I NIELSEN.
IRONIC YOU ROCK BY AMBER
[inaudible]
WILL I THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THAT TO IT.
OKAY THEY WERE HOLDING A LOVE
AND WE WILL BE HOLDING THE ROLF
VERY COUPLE OF THE MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH
.
OPEN THE ROOM [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LEADING GERMAN WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD OPEN THE ROLE AND EFFECT
DURING.
SENATE BILL TWO FORTY FIVE DO.
THROUGH RE REFER TO PREPARATIONS
GROWTH.
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
I NUMBER [inaudible]
NUMBER I SENATE THAT BILL DOES
THE BILL.
THE BILL HAS BEEN SENATE BILL.
TWO FOR SENATE BILL TWO FORTY
FIVE WILL PASS ON SENATE BILL
FIVE HUNDRED DO PASSED THE FIRST
REFERRED PERFORATIONS NIELSEN.
OFTEN I NUMBER.
HI NUMBER I BILL PASSES --
CENTER ON AS WELL.
SENATE BILL FIVE A ONE TO PASS
FIRST REFER TO RULES NUMBER
[inaudible]
NUMBER I SENATE BILL FIVE A ONE
WILL PASS ON THANK YOU.
SJR SEVEN TO BE ADOPTED GROWTH.
I NUMBER.
NUMBER. TWO AND THEN BILL PASSED
ON AS WELL THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THAT CONCLUDES OUR
MEETING FOR THE DAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU